how long after selling your first
screenplay did you sell your second
it happened pretty quick
because
um
the next screenplay i don't know if it
was the next thing we wrote but i come
up one day i was at the
tower records the old one that used to
have a video you could rent videos and
dvds sunset yes
they had two the one across the street
the one that you know had the dvd store
in it and i was looking at dvds i was
like
i had this idea it was like dario gento
i saw his he had a section i was like
his movies are cool and you know i
watched a lot of his movies from the 70s
it's like we should do a retro kind of
dario gento film and that was when
horror was really hitting its peak in
like 2007 2008 so it's like let's just
write like a 70s jello type
you know
thing that has all those tropes and just
have fun with it
and we did and literally like i don't
know how this happens is like two months
later this friend of mine who's from
italy goes oh you have something like
dario's movies i'll send it to dario or
like um like okay i didn't really know
this guy that well so and then i get a
call like a week later it's darya gento
on the phone from italy he's like i love
your script i want to do it
so
that movie got made i don't the universe
just wanted that movie to get made we
had a lot of problems with the
production um
but
it was just strange it was like one day
it's like and sometimes the universe
just kind of leads you right in certain
directions because i just was like you
know i like his movies let's do
something like his a retro you know 70s
throwback film and then he literally
directed it and adrien brody was in it
so you know it's how does this happen
you know from from the concept of being
in that video store like a year later i
was in italy on set so
sometimes things you know just have a
weird synergy projects have a weird
synergy too that's the other thing
people have to realize it's happened to
me on so many where i'm banging my head
trying to get this movie made and it's
just not working and then sometimes you
write something and every step of the
way it just snows balls it it connects
at the right time and right place i
don't know why but it just does and that
did
and it's about a missing model
yeah because that's what all the 70s
movies were about like missing pretty
girls so it it leaned into all those
tropes of it it was like this this girl
who was a model went missing her
sister's looking for her in a you know
and doesn't speak the language and finds
this american who actually does and
helps her out so yeah you know the
movies uh got some problems but it was
it was fun to make and it was a great
adventure and dario's an amazing person
and a great director another again i've
been i feel like
i've had the million dollar film school
because i've got to work with so many
great people
so
yeah so that was that was that taught me
a lot about how things can go wrong on a
movie which
i'm not going to go into too much detail
but a lot of stuff went wrong mostly
with the money
and the budgets and we didn't have as
much money to finish the film so halfway
through you find that out it's like it's
it was a real a lot of problems
not creatively but
on the business end of the film
was it filmed in italy yeah oh i see
okay yeah great wow it looks like a good
i gotta go to italy for three months
yeah that's nice that was fun to sell a
screenplay do you have to really believe
you can sell it
yeah
yeah i think you need to believe in in
the in the screenplay you have to
believe in
yeah because it's a hustle especially if
it's your first one so you need to
really believe in it you it needs to be
something that
you believe in something that you think
you could sell and you just need to be
kind of
relentless but if it doesn't work out
you need to move on to the next script
because the question is you need to ask
yourself
as a up and coming screenplay writer and
if you want to do this for a living do
you want to write things for yourself to
direct do you want to be a working
screenwriter because if you're if you
get to the level where
you're taking jobs which has happened to
me on several projects i'm getting hired
to write something you know there's like
an adaptation of a book or a comic book
so i don't have any say in the creative
thing but you know you can get paid very
well to like do that work so are you
doing it for yourself are you doing it
because you want to constantly write now
if you want to do it as a living you
know
in that sense where you're writing all
the time you don't get to choose all the
time what you want to write you know you
may have to do a rewrite you may have to
do this so it becomes more about work
than like
you know just believing just in the
project you have to believe in yourself
and it becomes more about like just
doing the work and doing the work
correctly and efficiently and you know
on time
so when things haven't panned out have
you had like a heart to heart with
yourself like well you know i didn't
really believe in it
yeah no i think because most
those those projects i'll get rid of
them before they get to that point like
i won't finish them or even if i do i'll
be honest about like i don't think
anybody's going to want to buy this i
think it's great
you know but
no one's going to want to make it
because the other thing too is like you
have to really realize that
in regards to indie films or smaller 10
million under film the only way they're
really going to get financed unless you
have a rich uncle is that you have to
have actors in them you have to name
actors that finance the film you can't
just ask somebody for five million
dollars and say
the guy from you know vampire diaries
who's the fifth lead is gonna be the
lead in it it's not gonna work they're
gonna wanna you know name actor they're
gonna be like okay we want frank grillo
and we want john travolta we want you
know to
make sure that we can make our money
back so you have to also think too is
that project appealing to actors that
will get your movie made
because that's a big important you know
component to the whole process
so
you've been in situations where you
think you like it but you don't think
others will or a producer will how do
you know that that's the case just
instinct just kind of knowing what you
know and it might not be the right time
to put something out too
you know because it's like okay these
movies are hot you know horror movies
are hot right now all anybody wants to
make are these so you just have to be
really honest with yourself and you know
it you can send it out but you only have
so many shots of like getting people to
read things too if you keep sending them
junk
you know you're not gonna get anywhere
even even i'm very careful never to send
my agents and managers too much stuff
because i'll be like oh that was okay
you know so i only try to send them the
best stuff that i do
can you think of a screenplay of yours
that you did not think would sell
and did
yes
broken vows
which
was made with jamie alexander and wes
bentley um
yeah it was just it was a script that
my writing partner and i wrote and then
we weren't really too happy with it we
knew it was good but it wasn't great
and we just kind of stuck it in a drawer
and then i got a call like two or three
years later from a producer friend of
mine said hey do you got anything that
can be made for two and a half million
dollars
and we're looking for a thriller or
something in that genre so i was like
yeah here we we never sent this out we
never gave it to our agent even to read
check it out it's good you know we can
maybe work on a little bit more make it
better
um
and then i get called like a week later
like okay cool we got the financing
let's make it
so
that was like literally like
just finding a movie in a drawer because
it was just sitting in a file
but
i also think two part of that is that
goes back to what i'm saying about
some of the stuff that i think is not up
to to par it's still i've written some
some things that are very professional
and could get made but i don't want to
like take my shots with those because i
just think they're not
you know maybe they're 90 and they're
not 100. so i think even something that
on my 90 because i've worked on so many
things is still good enough to turn into
a film
the opportunity just arose that this was
a good opportunity to take that
film that was like 90 there and they
were looking for something like that
so it worked great did you think it was
too edgy
no it just seemed
i don't know i don't know why it just
didn't it didn't even click with the
writers in some ways we knew it was good
but it didn't click with us
but then we worked out a little bit more
once it got serious and then it became a
different kind of film and became a
little bit better so i don't know it was
just a weird situation where uh
it was just script was sitting in a
drawer and end up getting fully financed
and made with great actors and you know
i think the actors brought a lot to it
too
so it's one of those projects that and
that's what you always want is your
screenplay can be here but hopefully the
the finished product's one step better
sometimes it goes the other direction
where you know i have one movie which
i'm not going to say which movie
which everybody who saw in the film
business was the screenplay was great
you know which that's very disheartening
you know when
it should get a step or two better when
when it's shot and edited and made into
a film
broken vows was like a
like a
romantic deception or yeah what was it
um sorry it's been a while um
yeah it was like a stalker movie but the
guy was a stalker you know usually you
saw it as as the girls the stalker now
they've had quite a few of those i think
we wrote it like 2008
and then it got made in 2013.
so it was it was that the guy was like
obsessed with the woman and i mean
they've made quite a few of those since
then so
it was wes bentley that yeah the
obsessed oh yes
yeah he's great great to work with a
great guy so
yeah
and so
from that time that you got that call
where they said hey what do you got
hanging around
when was the movie actually finished
what was the time frame probably about
a year later and we had to do the post
everybody chipped in i did the sound mix
the other producer did the color timing
so you know it took a little bit longer
to get made but yeah so it was made and
i think lionsgate lines get distributed
so so when they said what do you have
you said well i've got this thing and
you kind of were almost talking them out
of it before no just i didn't know what
they were really looking for so it was
just it was like okay you've got this
certain amount of money that you want to
invest in a film you're looking for this
type of film
um but i did tell them from the get-go i
was like this is the kind of film we can
easily cast because it's got some good
parts
you know for actors and they're you know
between 25 and 35 which is a really good
spot to find some good actors and we did